what is going on everybody welcome to
another Python 3 tutorial video in this
video what we're talking about is error
handling so in the last video we were
reading data from this example CSV and
we found real quickly though if the user
may be capitalized something that
wouldn't want to work but also what if
they enter a color that doesn't exist in
our list we handled the capitalization
stuff ourselves through some logic but
what if they entered tank ok pink is not
in the list right and it throws an error
and it just stops the entire program
from running so what we can do about
that is the following so when we have
what color equals that what we want to
use here is try and accept okay so what
trying to accept is going to do is it's
going to try a block of code and if
there's an exception it's going to do
something else so it's kind of like if
else if something is the case then we
would do it else whatever so it's going
to first try and if try succeeds it's
not going to run the exception so for
example we're going to say try here and
then we'll go ahead and we'll highlight
all this and just hit tab to tab it all
over so it's going to try this block of
code and if anywhere on this block of
code throws an error it it will go to
the exception here and we're going to go
accept capital e exception as E and if
you're coming from Python to seven it's
always good to know how to like port
between Python 2.7 and Python 3 and this
is a very popular try except it's very
popular and a lot of people will use
exceptions and so it's good idea to know
how to program this so if you have if
you're trying to port something over
this is a syntax difference so in Python
2 7 it will usually be except exception
comma E like that and then they'll work
with that whereas in Python 3 well first
of all this syntax doesn't really make
much of sense it's not very pythonic so
it was changed in Python 3 but anyway
moving right along so except exception
as E so it saves whatever the exception
is to the variable E and for now we'll
just print out the actual result of this
exception so we'll say
a print like that so we can save and run
it in fact hold on let me close out of
this one more time I just want to show
that the program is a break so
originally the program would break but
here it does not so say print continuing
there's still it there's a dog snort
under me I'm sorry if y'all can hear a
pink so pink is not in the list
continuing so it continues on even
though we did throw an exception so
that's kind of how we can handle that
now um there are a couple things that
you can do first of all we should kind
of see ahead of time that the color that
somebody enters first of all might not
have a color what if they entered like
one okay we should see ahead of time
that this list has a finite number of
colors and we can't handle everything
now with a dictionary or something you
can there's always a default value that
we can talk about that later but as far
as the list is concerned with there's an
infinite number of colors and spelling
and all that so then also the person
could just just straight-up typo and we
wouldn't want that to just bring the
whole application to a halt so anyway
you can put the try and accept here but
I think try and accept is best thought
of as a sort of final straw basically
before the whole whole thing comes to a
screeching halt you should have
something before so it's just like a
last-ditch effort to save the program so
instead what color will ask that
question but the only should kind of we
should come here and we should check we
should automatically as we're
programming this see that well this
might be problematic and so because when
you're programming stuff you kind of
want to like run it through in your head
and kind of think about like where could
this possibly go wrong and then you want
to kind of cater to that so for example
here we should kind of already have
thought well what a thinner color those
exist in the list so here what we can do
is if what color in colors so if
whatever this color is is in colors then
we want to run this entire block of code
right else
we can just print colored not found or
is not at color and that's it okay so
now we have this try and accept still
but we are not throwing an exception
because an exception is really just like
a catch-all now you can accept exception
you can accept you know something like
name error error are like that
so name error would be like if we
specify a variable that just simply does
not exist um then this name error would
be thrown so for example if we said
called X like that or something and we
said green write that exception is
thrown but only for a name error okay so
if we got rid of this like that um the
exception won't be thrown even if you
entered well even if we didn't have if
else here now if else will be triggered
now that we have it here but that name
error will only respond to a name error
then you could have another you know
exception value error and a specific
handling for value error and then a
specific and so on you have specific
error handling but again that's at the
final strong you throw an error and
otherwise the program wants to break so
that's like a catastrophic point whereas
if else is not really so catastrophic
that that shows that we had some
foresight as we were programming this so
anyway what color in colors called X so
we can run this we could say pink and
color and I founder is not a color and
the script continues right along so
anyways um that's going to conclude this
video so we kind of included try accept
and also the proper use of if else as
far as checking before we hit the try
and except some people might consider
that too much code though I like to use
try and accept and I usually own I just
use exception because exception in case
is pretty much everything so I like to
use that as like my final failsafe to
the program sometimes I even in case
like whenever you make a huge program
you have a what's known as a main loop
sometimes I encase that main loop in a
try and accept especially if this is
like a long-running task something that
I have usually an infinite loop on that
I
have it run forever I'll put everything
in a try and accept that way the program
never breaks but along the way you
should have lots of checks and if-else
statements and all sorts of stuff or at
least some sort of logging so you know
what's going on but anyway that's that's
all I got for this video if you guys
have any questions or comments feel free
to leave those in the section below as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all this for the subscriptions and it's
the next time